you can outwork anybody how bad as they
are I'm really good at creating an enemy
I'm really good at at creating something
that I'm against we had a guy died in
that throat hell week class 2:35 you got
to start diving into those things that
you are afraid of I became that big bad
nasty that you don't want to walk into
at nighttime need motivation watch a top
ten with believe nation what's that
belief nation it's Evan I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
can chew on today's lessons from a man
who went from growing up in an abusive
household barely graduating high school
and suffering from many serious health
issues to becoming a u.s. Navy SEAL and
one of the greatest endurance athletes
in the world he's David Goggins and
here's my take on his top ten rules a
success vol 4 also if you want to know
what David has to say about building
confidence and excellence check out my
250 for series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence the links to join are in the
description below
you will never learned from people if we
always tap-dance around the truth
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today
okay let's kick it off with your number
one outwork everyone where I got my work
ethic from was the hours I had to spend
learning this when you sit down and
you're not smart you have a disability
yeah and you still want to be in the top
of your class I didn't want to get by
what I realized that I can learn took
hard work and I can beat the
valedictorian in school but I got put in
ten hours more a day than he does know
what kind of strength comes from that
when you're sitting down that guy that
that valour towards money for an hour
and you know I caught you I caught you
and I am dumb but I have the work ethic
to catch you that's where David Ganga's
got really invented yeah was at a
kitchen table with 20 spiral notebooks
that were empty and then three months
later yeah they were full and you can go
through that after I have me in my
storage and you go through these power
notebooks of your life and you like this
is how I learned
this is unbelievable there's no miles
it's not about the models is that having
a discipline every day they say for me
to learn this one math problem it's
gonna take me ten hours mom and that's
where it and you realize do hard work
you can do you can outwork anybody how
bad as they are
but that's the part people don't want to
dive into rule number two find your
inner strength well there's something I
invented a long time ago and when you
have nothing to draw from I was able to
find strength in every molecule of this
earth I'm able to be in a room with
nothing with no motivation or
inspiration nothing and find it so what
I did in those situation was I invent
this thing called taking souls when
everybody's all up and you're exhausted
and you're weak and you're tired and
you're looking around and everybody
looks as bad as you or even worse I'm
like you know what I want to now make a
statement it's the perfect time to make
a statement
to make a statement to let you know
where your life ends in mine begins and
so the statement there is I must stop
every bit of strength from their looks
on their faces and how they feel and how
I'm gonna now from my childhood where I
came from how's the bottom of the barrel
I'm now amongst all these uncommon
people I'm now going to now make you
feel like your common so I used their
their sadness their weakness their parts
of their life for God this sucks I'm
like all poopy pants too messed up I
used that for my strength and I have
this moment of like let's say we're in
the sand we running or whatever I will
do a surge I would do something
everybody how's he doing this and from
that that look on their face that
feeling of God man this guy must be
something something special
it didn't services me further and
further and faster and harder for a long
time so it's energies everywhere but the
thing is it's so loud doc that that
voice in your head of pain and suffering
and discomfort and I don't want to do
this is so loud that you're unable to
really calm it down it's okay there's
something here
it's a patient calm that you have to
bring your substitute I know I have
something here but that voice is so
powerful that it's once you just let's
leave right we're done we're done it
spazzes you out and you want to go
versus saying let's take a second hang
on
before we [ __ ] out hang on and in
that moment you can think clearly and
find that strength out there for you
rule number three never give up my first
time going through buds I got the whole
week I'm stress fractures double
pneumonia
I get rolled back day one week one
second time going through buds I
actually fractured my patella before I
got in hell week made it through hell we
put the fractured patella went two weeks
after hell week and then cuz why I
didn't want to get rolled back to day
one week one yeah but I couldn't keep up
with the class got rolled back to day
one week one after hell week and then I
went through my third time and I
graduate that class we had a guy died
and that throat hell week class 235 so
that's kind of how it happened
rule number four face your obstacles how
do I get more confidence
it starts with yourself man you got to
start diving into those things that you
are afraid of you don't gain confidence
by going to the spot that makes you feel
good it could be a false reality in the
second life gives you that challenge all
you want to do is go back to what makes
you confidence or what gave you
confidence is that happy spot no what
gives you confidence what gave me
confidence was spending years at a
kitchen table trying to learn how to
read and write all my own realizing I
can't learn the way you learn I can't
but I can't learn but gives you
confidence not being afraid it's
overcoming the fear Isis stutter
severely bad so right now I'm know how
many people are gonna watch this know
what gives me confidence is knowing I'm
no longer care you know if I say you
start stuttering to you yeah that's what
gives me compass is facing these things
over coming up if you have not
overcoming them every day but facing
them and face in the face and pretty
like there's no one man this is where
it's at hmm it's not in that comfort
zone it's in the discomfort zone is
where my confidence is getting built
mm-hmm that's where it's getting built
but people want to they want to ease
your answer yeah there has to be an
easier way it's not I'm sorry I searched
for my entire life
rule number five prove them wrong I'm
really good at creating an enemy I'm
really good at creating something that
I'm against and I'm also good at if
you ever tell me something that I cannot
do I'm gonna let you know that I'm doing
it somehow somehow you're gonna know one
way or another that I'm doing it it may
not be like in your face it may I may
make sure that I run across the daggone
world so then it's on the news and you
turn the news on so how the hell did he
do that I want to do something that you
know I'm here I'm here
rule number six stop looking for finish
lines
[Music]
we're [ __ ] that one day
that finish line so we want to finish
what
pretty much everything we do if we're
sweaty beyond
remember this just because you were to
ask because it
you can work record very good morning
no guarantee success never expect
immediate results
you're gonna stay stuck anyone else to
victory comes
you know
room victory is your focus to work
abacus all rule number seven build
yourself up so many people before I give
them a workout playing the talk about
recovery
everybody everybody that hears me speak
they want to go straight to recovery
work out first huh work out first before
you talk to me about recovery how to
recover yeah work out first we are
always looking for like whenever I talk
to people people take my words and they
in they and they put it in a way to
where they want to feel comfortable this
guy you know they they they want to put
you in a box they want to put a title on
you know you're putting a title on me to
make yourself feel better about yourself
if you read this book of mine you see
where I came from this portion with this
portion was not built this business that
this person was not made by God mm-hmm
this person saw this person was built
I made this person I made this person by
diving in to the insecurities that life
gave me because now they're yours do
yours to own if you're not smart car
yourself dumb it's okay because you are
but take that knowledge you put yourself
down if you're fat car D so fat I used
to be 300 pounds hmm we we want to talk
so soft to ourself we're looking for
that recovery day and that recovery day
is everything in your life everything in
your life is that recovery day we're
looking for it's not coming it's not
coming
get over there recovery day and that's
the mentality I took with me and what
happened through that process was all
the frivolous things of life started to
float away I have to tell people lies so
they would like me hmm cuz I was so
insecure when you start to build
yourself up it start to have the one
thing that we don't have is confidence
yeah real authentic confidence from hard
work everything else goes away you no
longer look to other people for your
self-esteem elevation it's like oh yeah
you know no I walk in the room now and I
know the hours and years and decades I
put in a day to Gardens that's something
it's not on the wall it's not a trophy
on the wall it's not a medal on your
neck it is actually a feeling in your
heart and people watch every smile I
don't have to yeah yeah I think it was
look on my face I'm a very focused
person but the feeling I have in my soul
and in my heart that's why I need to
smile I don't need to smile I don't need
you to look at me and say oh my god you
look happy because helpless aren't happy
mm-hmm right we're giving you something
that we think you want to see I don't do
anymore I don't care how you perceive
David Goggins they get us do my journey
I figured out the one piece I was
missing I thought it was cars I thought
it was women I thought it was my body
but I thought was everything the one
piece I was missing was me having the
courage to face myself rule number eight
on your life I wanted that comfort zone
everybody looks for that pat on the back
they don't want to hear all the bad they
want everything that they're doing right
and I realized that it kept me in this
world that's what kept me in this world
I've not accomplishing anything so what
I did was I became that big bad nasty
that you don't want to walk into at
nighttime I became the roughest critic
in the world on myself and that's what
changed me I literally saw myself in the
mirror
I saw the truth for us to saying you
know my dad did this to me from you know
from beating me kids in school from call
me [ __ ] did this to me
my life do this to me my broken
foundation this to me I took that and
said you know what well some people may
help this happen but now I have to own
this no one's gonna come back to save me
no one's gonna come back on this couch
and say hey it's okay
you could be okay no I'm not I'm not
gonna be okay I didn't realize I had to
take a stand to make a real stand and it
was painful to look at who I look like
who I was what the world and myself
created it created a
a very lonely depressed insecure man
that would do anything just to have a
friend and I saw that as very pathetic
when you look at the truth it becomes
very ugly and pathetic rule number nine
seek challenges I started figuring out
going through buds was that the harder
some is the more it was challenged in my
mind so I had to find different ways to
stay in the fight in the state of the
fight
it got me tougher and tougher and
tougher so I'm actually happy I went
through three whole weeks
I never examined it myself there's a
human being you get examined yourself in
the night and I guess the best place to
examine yourself is maybe still hell
week three times so I got to exam myself
a few times so it started there
it started in hell week and it's still
going now at 43 years old and rule
number ten the last one before a very
special bonus clip is push your limits
some of you just don't get it I'm now
here trying to prove myself how tough I
am I'll try to make you think I'm trying
to give you tools on how to fire more of
yourself so why am I in the water right
now
at 3 o'clock in the morning well I was
going to training like to hate night
swims they bothered me we're not retired
I said I never get back in the water get
at nighttime so guess what I'm doing
right now going for a swim
at nighttime think about being better
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from David on how to show up every day
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
taking action in your life for business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what does owning
your life look like for you number two
what new challenges are you ready to
take on and number three how will you
build yourself up to do it
it's 44 degrees and it's nice and rainy
outside but no one curious about that
it's not about the rain before the rain
represents license always giving you a
test trying to give you a way out
trying to give you your juice not to
show up this is my excuse today but
guess what gotta have the mentality to
show up every day is your life it's
about what life throws at you it's our
responsibility just songs to the
Coliseum of life prepare for battle I'll
kill what you're going through what
life's thrown at you it's your
responsibility to find your new hundred
percent take it upon yourself to do that
stay hard
if you want more David Goggin check out
the last top ten rules video on him I
think you legged the link is right there
next to me and if you want a bonus PDF
of all of these rules in a beautiful
download check the link in the
description below back out of shape is
secure I was everything everybody said I
was going to be